collectively the world's 10 highest paid
athletes raked in
992 million dollars over the last 12
months before taxes and agents fees
according to forbes's estimates
this year's total is the third highest
ever behind two years in which conor
mcgregor skewed the results in 2021 with
the sale of his irish whiskey brand
proper number 12 and in 2018 after his
boxing super fight against floyd
mayweather in one clear sign that
sport's top stars are doing better than
ever the cutoff to make the top 10 this
year is 80.9 million dollars posted by
giannis anta de cumpo of the milwaukee
bucks that's an 8 jump from 2021's
record high of 75 million dollars with
neymar turning 30 in february anta de
cumpo is the only member of this year's
top 10 still in his 20s the two-time nba
mvp signed a five-year 228 million
dollar contract in december of 2020 the
league's largest contract by total value
to date at number nine is tom brady who
made 83.9 million dollars while brady
plans to hit the field for his 23rd
season in the nfl he's got a number of
off-field ventures that have helped push
up his fortune autograph the nft
platform he co-founded last year raised
170 million dollars in the series b
funding round announced in january
meanwhile one of his production
companies 199 productions is behind the
upcoming road trip movie 80 for brady
and he has a new clothing line cleverly
named brady and when it's finally time
to retire permanently from football
brady already has the next gig lined up
a commentator role with fox sports
according to the new york post that deal
is set to pay him more than he's earned
on the field across 22 seasons in the
nfl
375 million dollars over 10 years
at number eight is canelo alvarez who
made 90 million dollars
alvarez is boxing's top draw earning 40
million dollars or more from his two
pay-per-view victories last may and
november beyond the ring alvarez has a
lucrative partnership with hennessy and
said last year that he would be
launching a chain of gas stations in his
native mexico
at number 7 is roger federer who made
90.7 million dollars
injuries limited federer to six
tournaments in 2020 and 2021 combined
and he has yet to return to the tennis
court in 2022
no matter the world's former number one
player remains the top pitch man in
sports promoting brands such as uniqlo
and rolex he also invested in the
burgeoning swiss shoe brand on in 2019
and the company went public in september
raising more than 600 million dollars
at number six is kevin durant who made
92.1 million dollars
the brooklyn netstar brings in roughly
28 million dollars annually from nike a
sneaker deal surpassed only by lebron
james is among active players duran has
recently added deals with coinbase nba
top shot and weed maps but with media
company boardroom and investment firm 35
ventures his business empire goes far
beyond endorsements
at number 5 is steph curry who made 92.8
million dollars
no nba player made more in salary this
season than curry and the golden state
warriors guard is due for a raise after
signing a four year 215 million dollar
extension last august curry's new ftx
endorsement deal came with an equity
stake and he dived deeper into
blockchain in december releasing a
collection of nfts that featured his
sneakers and were tied to three
miniverse platforms
at number four is neymar who made 95
million dollars
neymar scored his 400th career goal in
november but he was stung by criticism
after paris saint-germain's early
champions league exit off the pitch he
has a valuable set of endorsements
including puma and red bull and he's
diving into the world of nfts signing
with the platform and ft star in
november
at number three is cristiano ronaldo who
made 115 million dollars much of
ronaldo's earning power comes from his
massive social media presence he has 690
million followers across instagram
facebook and twitter giving him leverage
to demand sky-high rates from sponsors
such as nike herbalife and clear shampoo
he's also the face of zuju gp a
forthcoming app aiming to be a digital
soccer community
at number two is lebron james who made
121.2 million dollars james's los
angeles lakers missed the playoffs this
season but he's never been so dominant
off the court in october he sold a
significant minority stake in his
production company spring hill at a
valuation of about
725 million dollars pushing his net
worth to 850 million dollars according
to forbes's estimates james also became
only the 10th athlete in the history of
the forbes list that surpassed 100
million dollars in earning in a single
year
and at number one is lionel messi who
made 130 million dollars
messi claims the top spot in forbes's
annual ranking for the second time
messi's new 20 million dollar a year
partnership with fan engagement app
socios adds to an endorsement portfolio
that includes adidas budweiser and
pepsico he also became hard rock
international's first athlete brand
ambassador in a deal announced last june
helping messi draw level with ronaldo
with his off-field earnings for the
first time since 2013. both made an
estimated 55 million dollars off the
field over the last 12 months
you